The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES GERACI: My
name's James Geraci.
I worked with Sudarshan and
John Chu on this project.
And what we did is we took
a numerical simulation,
electrochemical
simulation, of a battery
and ported it to
the Playstation 3.
So the objective of this
project for this situation
was to port an electrochemical
simulation to the PlayStation 3
and try to take advantage of
the unique features of the cell
processor to help speed up the
computation of the simulation.
So when we talk to everyone, we
talk why we'd want to do that.
We're going to
discuss the model.
We're going to discuss how
we solved it numerically,
look at some of our
performance results,
and then discuss what we wish
we could have implemented.
So the justification is
basically the world needs
energy, and oil has
been in the news a lot
and hasn't been as a reliable
source of energy as we'd like.
So in the automotive
industry, hybrids
seem to be part of the
solution to the energy needs.
Now, one the problems
of hybrids is how much
energy is in your battery.
So the more
sophisticated battery
model that we can put
in a hybrid, the better
that we're going to be off.
So a more sophisticated model
requires more computation,
so you're looking at
having a large superscalar
processor in your
car, or you could
see if you could get a
lot of small processors
to do the same amount of work.
And the cell represents
the first opportunity
be able to test that out.
So the simulation
that we ran basically
consisted of a lead
acid battery cell.
So unfortunately, they
used the word "cell,"
and we're also using
the word "cell."
So it's sort of like
the modern day Smurf.
So in a lead-acid
battery cell, you
have a lead dioxide
electrode, which
consists of a number of
parts; a lead electrode,
which also consists
of a number of parts;
and an electrolyte, which is
5 molar sulfuric acid, which
consists of H2SO4.
When you discharge
the battery, you're
going to close the circuit.
And basically, what
ends up happening is
you have electrons
flying on the outer loop.
And between the
electrodes, you're
going to have an ionic current.
So you have a complete
circuit around your loop.
And this is the effect
that the simulation
is trying to simulate.
The simulation works on a
very low physical level,
and it stimulates the
chemical reactions, which
at the lead dioxide
electrode, it
converts lead dioxide into
lead sulfate during discharge,
reverses it during charge.
During discharge,
the lead electrode
turns lead into lead sulfate.
And during recharge,
it converts that back.
To implement the model, we
took basically and discretized
the system and just
kind of cross-sectioned
it-- took small sections
and cross-sectioned it.
We're going to skip this slide.
I don't know what that is.
But basically, to
simulate the physics,
we have a bunch of
nasty, nonlinear coupled
partial differential equations.
This is an example
of two of them.
And there are a
number of other ones
that are included in the system
but not really worth seeing.
Just kind of a feel, you
see a diffusion term.
In the lower equation,
you see a diffusion term.
You see a reaction term.
And the upper equation, you
see changing of the porosity,
changing the geometry
of the system.
This is kind of
the output that you
could get from this type
of battery simulation.
And what you're
looking at here is
you're looking at-- if
the left-hand side is
the electrodes, is the
top of the battery,
and the height of the
battery goes along that way,
you see that as you
discharge, the concentration
at the top of the electrodes
is much-- the acid is
consumed where you're drawing
current out most readily.
So physically, the simulation
kind of makes sense,
even if my speech didn't.
The battery model that we used
is a two-dimensional model.
It has both a lead dioxide
electrode and a lead electrode
and an electrolyte area.
This is an example of just
the lead dioxide electrode.
And if we discretize
that in two dimensions,
we would get a
discretization that
looks like that
if we were to use
a single-centered
finite-volume method.
But it turns out that we have
so many discontinuities in here
that it's much better
to use a staggered grid.
And so we're using actually
two different meshes
to simulate this system.
Well, on a single
mesh, you would end up
having four corners,
four edges and a center.
So you would get nine
different types of objects
and one electrode alone.
And you're talking about
a rather large and nasty
simulation.
On a small scale,
the simulation would
produce a very sparse matrix
that looks something like this.
And Sudarshan will
now come up and talk
to you about the matrices and
how we solved this system.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
[INAUDIBLE] slight context
[INAUDIBLE] speakers.
So basically, like John said,
the problem, we are essentially
trying to parallelize the most
computationally expensive part
of this whole
simulation, this solving
for the Newton iterations
during each [? lower ?] step.
And so basically, in an
abstract-- I'm sorry.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Speak louder.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Louder.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The microphone [INAUDIBLE].
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
I'll try, but you've got
to try and listen harder too.
PROFESSOR: That only
works for the TV.
You have to yell at them.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
I got it, yeah.
Is it any better now?
PROFESSOR: No, you've
got to yell at them.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
Is it any better now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: OK, cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I can hear.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: So--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I always like to say
I'll try to speak harder.
You should try to
listen harder, too.
So we meet somewhere in between.
So basically in
an abstract sense,
we are trying to solve a system
of sparse linear equations.
And for simplicity,
for the first pass,
we treated the matrix
as being dense.
So we did the whole Gauss
elimination ignoring
all the zeroes of the matrix.
And so the basic idea is
that we do Gauss elimination
with partial pivoting.
And it's the forward elimination
stage of the Gauss elimination
that [? Rn cubed ?]
that is most expensive.
And that is the thing
we've tried to parallelize
between among the SPUs.
And the partial pivoting and the
back subs are done on the PPUs
because that turned
out to be much faster.
So this is the matrix
that we are considering
during each step for
the random entries
and for the random
right-hand side.
And then so the way
Gauss elimination works
is that we start off
with one of the rows
that you call the
base row, which
is where the pivots come from.
And then we eliminate the
variable corresponding
to base row from all the
subsequent elimination rows.
And all these eliminations
can be done in parallel.
And that's what we have
tried to parallelize.
So each SPU grabs hold of the
next available elimination row,
eliminates it, and
writes a result back
on to the main memory.
So if, for example,
if we consider
the situation with the
two SPUs, what we do
is that we stream
the elimination rows
across all the SPUs.
Each SPU performs
the elimination
and writes the result back to
main memory, as you can see.
And this happens for every row.
So in this simulation, the first
variable has been eliminated.
As you can see, there are
zeroes along the first column.
And the process is recursive.
After the first
variable is completed,
it moves on to
the next variable.
And the way the elimination
rows are returned,
they're delivered in
a cyclical fashion.
So there is no
serial bottleneck.
It's all perfectly
load balanced.
PROFESSOR: Have you--
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
I'm sorry?
PROFESSOR: --change?
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
I'm sorry?
PROFESSOR: If you
eliminate something lower,
doesn't the pivot value change?
I'm completely not getting
what you are saying.
That's my first question.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Second question
is, is this sparse or dense?
What's your matrix
representation?
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: The
matrix representation currently
is dense.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
Yeah, so we've--
PROFESSOR: Doesn't
the pivot value
keep changing when
you eliminate?
So if it's completely parallel,
and doesn't that [INAUDIBLE]?
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: So
all the subsequent variables
that are eliminated
for each variable,
all can be done in parallel.
But after one variable
has been eliminated,
there's a synchronization
step where all the SPUs
have to synchronize.
There's a barrier after each
row has been eliminated.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
Yeah, so you start it--
so there's a
totally [INAUDIBLE],
if you write the algorithm down.
And then it's the
inner two loops that
are totally parallelized with.
And the second loop is what
we're trying to parallelize.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN:
Is that a little clearer?
Yeah.
So this is the basic algorithm.
And I'll let John talk about
some of the performance numbers
we've got.
But some of the optimizations
that we haven't done
are the use of the
[? last three ?] operations,
like extreme multiple
rows at a time and use
of [INAUDIBLE] operations.
But I'll let John talk about
the performance numbers.
JOHN CHU: Computation of
the current elimination
row with the fetching of
the next elimination row,
we get roughly a 30% speedup.
So here's a graph
to see how both
the unbuffered and buffered
version perform scattered
with a number of SPUs.
So as you can see, both
look roughly pretty linear.
And that makes
sense because the--
So here's another
graph of how we
scaled with the size of the
matrix that we're working with.
So the smaller the
matrix, the higher
the communication/computation
ratio.
So the communication latency
should be more apparent.
But as you can see,
even as you get smaller,
the computations is
still pretty linear.
So--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's linear.
But it's not just [INAUDIBLE].
It's not running at 2x
performance improvement.
But [INAUDIBLE] now.
So when you put 16 there,
why is it only 30%?
Why is it not leading to
2x performance improvement?
So is it because of underclock?
Because if it's
underclocked, your graph
shouldn't have this
kind of a pattern.
It should have a more
exponential type pattern.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Did you
understand the question?
JOHN CHU: Yep.
PROFESSOR: So why aren't
you getting a 2x speedup?
I mean, your line is
straight, but it's not
increasing proportional
to the number of SPUs
you're increasing.
So your efficiency
might not be at 100%.
Any idea why?
JAMES GERACI: Yeah, that
[? looks ?] horrible.
JOHN CHU: The 2x
is only-- this is
[INAUDIBLE] [? laptop ?],
so two would only
shift it up and down, right?
PROFESSOR: So it looks
like you're not operating
at 100% efficiency, right?
JAMES GERACI: Oh,
definitely not.
JOHN CHU: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So I think to--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
conversation going on there.
But this a strange
type of a graph
because if [INAUDIBLE] as
you get a very nice linear
[INAUDIBLE].
If you have [? undersize ?]
coordinate, what you get
is you have a good
speed at very beginning,
and then you slow down.
You get a [INAUDIBLE]
type of a graph.
So it's very much--
I haven't seen things
like a strange line, but not
as [INAUDIBLE] on your graph.
This is kind of a strange
thing. [INAUDIBLE]
to see where and
why does it happen.
JOHN CHU: OK.
Well, yeah, so
I'll just move on.
So I'll talk about some
of the further work
we're trying to do.
PROFESSOR: John?
JOHN CHU: Yeah?
PROFESSOR: Can you clip the mic
to your-- yeah, that'll work.
JOHN CHU: So we've also
tried to triple buffer
by pipelining the
fetching of the next row
with the computation
of the current row
with the sending of
the previous row.
We did this, but
it didn't actually
give us the speedup that
we thought we would get.
But what we're working on how
is SIMDizing the computation
stage.
So right now, we treat all the
doubles in the rows as scalars.
But by SIMDizing, hopefully
we can get a speedup
by a factor of two.
And also right now,
our LU algorithm
isn't very smart in that
when we fetch the elimination
row, as we go on
through the algorithm,
part of the elimination row
becomes zeroes as we move down.
So we don't really need to fetch
the entire elimination row.
And so by taking
that into account,
our DMA transfers are smaller.
And maybe that will help
speed up things a bit.
PROFESSOR: So is the whole
thing using double precision?
JOHN CHU: Yes.
It's in double precision.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
megaflops you're getting?
JAMES GERACI: We have gigaflops.
I think we're getting
around 2 gigaflops.
JOHN CHU: So here's
the gigaflops graph.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what
the expected for [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES GERACI: [INAUDIBLE]
algorithm bias, just
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: This is a linear
scalar on the y-axis?
JAMES GERACI: Yeah,
it's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Any idea why you have
this [INAUDIBLE] at 3 SGUs?
Your double buffering
result just drops.
JAMES GERACI: Actually,
we have no idea.
[INAUDIBLE]
I don't know if we consistently
checked [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You might want
to run it a few more times.
There is a recent
series of papers
by Jack Dongarra's
group aimed at
double-precision computations.
They used single precision,
did an approximate guess,
and then did a few iterations
of an iterative approach
to get a
double-precision result.
JAMES GERACI: Yeah, those don't
work very well for [INAUDIBLE].
And this is conditioned
around 10 to the 8.
So that's kind of out of the
ballpark of the [INAUDIBLE].
SUDARSHAN RAGHUNATHAN: And
the particle [INAUDIBLE]
that they do, they tried to
do [INAUDIBLE] computation.
And the main reason they do
[INAUDIBLE] because they say
[INAUDIBLE].
And then in doing
this, the hope is
to generalize this to
sparse matrices later on.
And I think they
are trying to do
some work with sparse matrices,
but they haven't gotten there.
AUDIENCE: One
additional question.
Just at a high level,
is this the right way
to tackle this
particular problem?
It strikes me that there must
be a closed-form high-level
microscopic model for
battery self-discharge.
And I don't know anything
about the chemistry lead
acid batteries, but the
little write-up on the website
mentions Black-Scholes, which
I do know something about.
And of course, there are
efficient ways of doing that.
JAMES GERACI: Sure,
there are efficient ways
of doing Black-Scholes.
There are different
ways of doing this.
This is only one of
the equations that's
similar to Black-Scholes.
There are multiple
equations that go into this.
They're all coupled.
They're all nonlinear.
So solving this
system of equations
is, in the literature, if
you were going to choose
this as your model, is--
AUDIENCE: But if
you were actually
in the business of building
and operating batteries--
JAMES GERACI: The problem with--
AUDIENCE: --wouldn't you try
and come up with an efficient
microscopic model rather than--
JAMES GERACI: Well, it depends
on what your compute costs are.
I mean, if you're going to
run a model on a superscalar
processor, that' very
expensive processor.
If, however, now
you have the ability
to use a collection of small,
cheap little processors
like this, you can
maybe have the luxury
of using a much more
sophisticated model.
AUDIENCE: Is it necessarily
more sophisticated?
I mean, is there some
fundamental reason
why you'd get more information
out of this approach than
out of a higher level model?
JAMES GERACI: You get a lot
more detail as to what's
going on within your battery.
A higher level model will
give you I/O information.
But if you're trying to
find failure mechanisms,
you may want to know
how much pressure's
going on at certain
points in your battery.
Especially with
lithium ion batteries,
when you-- this differs
from a lithium ion
battery in that we're actually
changing the state, the type
of matter that we're using.
And in lithium
ion battery, we're
intercalating and
deintercalating.
And so what we're doing is
we're creating a lot of stress
on a matrix, a crystal.
And that will be a
failure mechanism.
A simple input/output
relationship
will not give you that
failure mechanism.
So you may want to know
that kind of information.
You may want to know
heat information also.
You could include
thermodynamical information
to this kind of model.
AUDIENCE: OK, that's
a good answer.
I take that to mean that
the reason for doing this
is if your researching
the physics of battery
discharge as opposed to trying
to estimate how much power's
left in your battery.
JAMES GERACI: Well, if you
have the computation power,
you could use the
same model that
does the research as the car.
And so if you-- yeah, if you
can use small processors.
So our demonstration--
if you guys want to see
print def statements.
Otherwise--
PROFESSOR: No, I
think we're over time.
JAMES GERACI: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Any last questions?
AUDIENCE: Wait,
just so I understand
the sparse versus dense
issue, if you just
do a sparse elimination
on a uniprocessor,
do you get a bigger speedup?
JAMES GERACI: Oh, you get
a much bigger speedup.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAMES GERACI: The LU is
about the slowest thing
you could possibly
choose, but if it works.
AUDIENCE: OK, but what
you have would still
usable for dense matrices?
JAMES GERACI: It'd still be
useful for dense matrices,
yeah.
AUDIENCE: And do you
compare it all to just PPU
performance on a dense matrix?
JAMES GERACI: No, we didn't
compare it to the PPU.
We had it compared-- the same
model I'm running on a PC.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK,
thank you, speakers.
[APPLAUSE]